Yeah,
there are many big challenges today.
On the one hand,
there are the mass atrocities.
Places liked r four or I'm eastern
Congo,
where where many,
many people are killed and displaced.
There are highly repressive governments,
say North Korea or Burma or Uzbekistan
or Turkmenistan where just the severity
of the government repression deserves
attention.
There are places where wars have become
so chaotic that,
that the lack of government is a
problem.
I think Iraq as an example of that.
So in that sense,
there are many situations where,
where violence and repression call out
for urgent attention,
but there are other,
you know,
quieter forms of abuse that we tend not
to,
you tend not to see in the headlines,
but that nonetheless affect many,
many people quite severely.
And here I think about say that the
severe restrictions on,
on the rights of women that exist in
many parts of the world.
Um,
I think about migrant workers who were
forced to travel long distances and in a
foreign environment often are exist
completely without respect for rights.
I'm wholly at the whim of their
employer.
I think about,
you know,
children who may be drafted to be
soldiers,
I'll Mariano physically seized and
course to become soldiers or who have to
serve as as domestics in lieu of going
to school.
So there are many of these quieter
issues that don't get into the
headlines,
but that are also quite acute problems
as well.